my name is Katie VAR and I work at the
genome analysis center which is based on
the Norwich research park so it is a
research institution but it's not a
university and so yeah I only started
doing plant biology at the beginning of
last December so please forgive me for
my lack of any understanding about
plants whatsoever and so the genome
analysis center kind of does exactly
what it sounds like it does we analyze
genomes and so this is kind of the field
of genomics which was spawned when we
first sequence the human genome about 15
16 years ago now so at the time that was
a massive massive technological feat and
is divided up between teams all the way
around the world and people kind of did
it one chromosome at a time and now
we've had massive advantage advances in
sequencing technology and which means
that we can get loads more genomes and
and analyze them in a sort of much more
detail than we've ever been able to
before and this has also spawned massive
advances in sort of bioinformatics
because obviously we're creating huge
amounts of data and if you can't analyze
those amounts of data then well its
pretty well useless and so the aim of
research that I'm working on is to
identify variation within the wheat
genome and this is basically so we can
hopefully isolate variations which will
cause desirable properties and and this
will enable growers to two strains based
on genomic properties rather than by
trial and error so you can say by
looking at the genome that you this is
an appropriate kind of seed for you to
grow for your environment and in sort of
the wake of climate change this is
becoming particularly important and
instead of having to wait
while we'll see your crop fail you know
that you're going to grow the right
thing and this kind of approach has been
tested recently the El Nino and it has
caused huge droughts in sub-saharan
Africa and the Red Cross in Kenya knew
which areas in Kenya we're going to be
particularly prone to drought and they
gave the farmers their seeds food
drought resistant wheat and that means
that people haven't starved to death
basically which is the other option so
why am i studying wheat and because it's
not well understood and it's only
explain how its kind of different in the
next slide it's a really important food
crops so twenty percent of all of the
calories consumed by humanity and come
from wheat thirty five percent of us
depend on it for our survival so and
there's basically a huge amount of money
and in solving these problems around
guaranteeing future yields because so
many of us depend on it and also it's
biologically interesting so it's
actually three genomes combined into one
plant so humans have pairs of
chromosomes and and wheat started off as
three separate grass and plants each of
these had pairs of chromosomes and way
way way back two of them kind of came
together and so then you had two pairs
of chromosomes and then about 10,000
years ago yet another grass species and
was introduced and that happened in the
Fertile Crescent and if you read the
sort of introduction to nature articles
about wheat then they say that this
caused the birth of civilization I'm
really not a historian but I can sort of
believe that having such an important
food crops suddenly a pair up Nova
probably did help a little bit and
it's difficult because in differs by up
to sixty percent between varieties so if
you're in the other talked earlier
saying about how similar humans are to
each other and if you took sixty percent
of another genome and added it to you
like you wouldn't even be a viable
organism like there's no way you'd still
recognizably be human right you just be
dead so the fact that it can tolerate
this and we think it can tolerate this
because it's got this huge amount of
redundancy with the three genomes and so
it's yeah are new to biology but I can
sort of see why this is biologically
interesting and and yeah it can contain
large regions of DNA from other plants
which I've sort just basically said so
there's a large in one of the strange
that I study like there's a huge section
of like one of the chromosomes that just
is another plant species and so yeah and
and it's not well understood because
it's more difficult to kind of analyze
and then well humans and a lot of other
like sort of model organisms and and
that's partly because a lot of the
technologies being developed for humans
rather than plants and and we're kind of
just trying to shoehorn it into working
in this situation and it's because it
it's not vastly bigger than the human
genome but it's big enough the given
assualt complexity of the algorithms
used by bioinformaticians it makes a
massive massive difference in terms of
one time and your memory requirements so
it's difficult to analyze and its really
hugely repetitive and so more than
eighty percent of the genome is repeats
and a lot of these repeats are really
really simple so they are things like
this example that I've got here and that
makes it quite difficult to assemble
like to start off in any genomic
research you
you what you call a reference genome
which is your kind of canonical sequence
of DNA that you say this is this
organism and to get one of those and you
need to assemble all your land sequences
and it's really difficult you get a
short read and say if you have a short
read ta then we're on earth in that
sequence is supposed to actually map it
well you don't know so part of the
reason that we're doing this research
now is because sequencing technology is
now such that we can get reads that are
longer than the repeat so we don't have
to worry about kind of getting the
repeating sections all going together in
the same way because you know what's at
the start and end of those sections so
and that's one of the things that has
spawned the sort of recent and advances
and and yeah so techniques used to
analyze other organisms are difficult to
apply here that's partly because it's
got the sort of like three separate
genomes and it's yeah it's partly just
because it's a bit larger than other
things and a lot of like bioinformatics
software like assumes that you're using
us or model organism where there's a
like large database already available of
stuff to use and we just don't have that
in this case and so we're starting quite
small and just looking at two strains
these are kind of like what we call like
elite kind of UK crop strains so the
first one is called Chinese spring and
the reason we're looking at that is
because actually the genome analysis
center in December last year published a
very very high quality reference genome
of Chinese spring and we just also at
the same time did a load more sequencing
of this other variety called cadenza so
from my perspective the reason
using these is just kind of like
pragmatic I didn't choose what strains
would be used it's just the data that
we've got but on developing pipelines
which can be used in and when we get new
strange sequence which is actually
worked at somebody going at the moment
and so I put this sliding because I
really like one of you guys to tell me
that it's not really different and I'm
just missing something really obvious
that's going to make my life a lot
easier so like the main I i come from a
computational physics background and and
everything now is just numbers all sorts
of categorical data so i was doing sort
of quantum computing and we got like
probabilities of being in certain state
or if you're looking at like state
machines it was like it yes or no has it
accepted this input and whereas here we
have these sort of just long run by well
they seemed to me some random sequences
of characters they're really not a home
and and at the outset you don't know
like anything about what these sequences
mean and so you don't know that's a gene
or you don't know like you just
literally have the sort of text data and
and you get some quality scores out of
your sequencing machines as well to tell
you how sure it is about the and
sequences so once you've got your reads
if you align them then you've got your
positions on the reference genome and
for hugely repetitive things we're
obviously not always sure about where on
the reference genome it should have gone
because there are loads of potential
places it could go so the alignment
algorithms also output quality scores
and and then I'll use sort of variant
callers which they take the quality
scores of everything going beforehand
and they put their own quality schools
as well and so and then depending on
your eventual kind of
intentions like there is a lot more that
you can take into account so there can
be a lot of contextual data like and
especially if you want to know things
like is this a gene region or not so
yeah and mostly I feel like it's
different just because is all of this
kind of like text data that it's you
can't really use like any languaging
processing things because it's not kind
of nicely divided into words and and so
yeah it's quite different to anything
that I personally about before and so I
should tell you what variation is so
again if you're in the talk earlier then
you'll already know what a snip is so
this is a single nucleotide polymorphism
and I'm say this is literally when you
just change one nucleotide base so here
I've got it tuning from C to G and and
in general you only expect like one type
of polymorphism at a particular position
and slightly more complex tonight you
can get an insertion or deletion and and
so that's where you get bits of DNA that
just been added or removed and then you
can get copy number variants where
different bits have been sort of copied
fewer or more times than they were in
the original and anything at am presence
or absence so here entire regions are
missing in one variety but present in
another and to work that out you need to
actually define what a region is so
presence or absence is kind of
determined by what you're actually
interested in for the problem you're
trying to solve and then you can get
some ways structural variations so these
are I think presence and absence and and
sort of sceneries are probably come
under structural variations really but
you can get much larger variations so
gaining the talk earlier he mentioned
about how in reproduction like things
can get a swapped
around in quite a lot of ways and this
can cause like large differences on
particular chromosomes and so that's
structural variation so the standard
approach to finding variations is the
sequin cdna aiming for lots of reeds at
each position on the genome the
sequencing technologies can't actually
tell you yes I have 50 reads at each
position on the genome and what they
tell you is I have 50 times more data
than it is contained in the genome so we
use that to kind of think okay all our
fridge there are probably 50 reads at
each position and but that does mean
that in the data I've been looking at we
have some positions where we've actually
only got three or four reads at a
particular position and if they tend to
disagree as well then that makes things
a bit more difficult and so then you
align your sequences so when you sequin
cdna you smash it up into loads of
little pieces and and so it's not
obvious where they came from so then you
need to make a decision about where
along your reference genome they come
from and and then once you have and
you're sort of sequences align to your
reference genome then you run your
variant calling software there's a
ridiculous proliferation a variant
calling software and so a lot of them
work on kind of like Bayesian statistics
so just working out the probability
given the a sort of sequence that you
have like whether it's more likely to be
a very Noren error and and you can have
very sort of complex and sort of
probability calculations that take and a
lot of data into account so like you're
sort of flanking sequences and how close
you are to other types of variations so
how likely it is that you've just made a
massive mistake in your data there and
in some very simple ones
I can't present a comment on whether the
sort of simple versions are better than
the more complex versions for them so
then you need to filter and sanity check
your results and which is pretty
standard for any sort of white data
science really and and then this is the
bit that it's sticky for us so in human
studies or mouse studies or something
like that and like you can then do much
cheaper sequencing and just get like one
copy of a genome from like say 100
individuals and if that variant is
present in a significant number of those
individuals then you say yes I've
genuinely found a variant and so I'll
explain why that's difficult in our case
slightly later on so now because i went
over the whole thing quite quickly I'm
just going on to more detail about it so
I sort of consider the problem of
alignment as if you've shredded lots of
copies of slightly different versions of
the same book and what you want to get
out of it at the end is a kind of the
position of each shredded bit of paper
in your book and and so it kind of seems
like it's easy to do and if you think
valla in terms of words and but if you
think about it in terms of kind of these
four nucleotide base sequences it's much
more difficult so my alignment files and
because we're not really sure where a
lot of things go you get a lot of kind
of secondary possible alignment so the
wheat genome is 17 Giga bases long and
that actually translates into a file of
about seventeen gigabytes but my
compressed alignment files are about
half a terabyte so we have when I say
you need to filter in some sanity check
I really mean you need to filter in
sanity check we have so one one thing
that people are doing where I work is
working out techniques they're much more
suited to these sorts of genomes and so
hopefully in the future we won't have
those problems so a few basic sanity
checks that you can do for variations
and so one thing that you look at is
what you call it TS to TV ratio so this
is for snips and if you're changing
nucleotide bases then there are sort of
three ways that you can change and one
of those ways is called a transversion
or well to the recorder transversion the
other one's called a transition and it's
not actually a two-to-one ratio and due
to the sort of chemistry of the
nucleotide bases like some and
differences i think is it c gets
methylated i'm looking at you because
you i imagine that you'd have a better
idea but I ok it's then ok in a bit
apparently that makes it more likely to
kind of do be a transition or
transferred and I can't remember which
but also like this so firstly is not
known for wheat so I'm kind of like just
try to compare my values to other
grasses and hope that that's okay but
then what i found out when i was looking
at the papers for other grasses is that
it depends like this t esta TV ratio i
actually depends on the flanking
sequences of your snips so if you're in
a very high 80 content region then like
your ratio is going to be different too
and what it is in a very high sort of
white GC content region and that's
partly because these regions like kind
of mean different things and genetically
and aren't I'm guessing there's probably
some chemistry involved as well so like
and this is the sort of thing that's
really easy to do for you
and it's kind of not easy at all to do
for sort of non-model organisms and you
can also look at coding versus
non-coding regions so the protein-coding
regions may well be less tolerant in
general to variation than non-protein
coding regions because if you have a
protein coding region that is where the
proteins are like really fundamental to
some processes in life then a variation
there is going like cause an organism
that isn't viable like we're just never
going to see those happen because
they've just died and and also within
the coding regions and synonymous
variants so ones that create the same
protein are expected to occur more
frequently for the same reason like if
you change the protein that's being
coded then and it may lead to kind of
disastrous that affects biologically and
to work these up you need to know where
the coding and non-coding regions of
your DNA actually are and I think the
annotation for the reference genome now
I mentioned before so this is the
reference you know I'm talking about is
open source by the way and the
annotation is I think going to be made
open source in a couple of weeks so then
you can go and see for yourselves what
the coding and non-coding regions are
and then determining within the coding
regions whether the variants are
synonymous is also am not that simple
I've SAT a script running over a week
ago just check that and it's still not
finished soham yeah my sanity checking
is an ongoing process I hope but
hopefully at the end and we're going to
prove that we've got really high quality
data set and deal with the obvious thing
you can look at is the overall frequency
of variations and we expect those to be
about 100 at one per hundred base pass
so yeah and so validating new varying
and so we can't do the kind of like skim
sequencing and loads of individuals just
to see if they have a particular variant
because we don't have individuals like
these sort of like elite crops trains
are all clones so they're all
genetically identical to each other so
we need a new approach to verify new
variants and we're basically trying to
do that by working out what false
positives look like and by am running
the exact same pipeline on the Chinese
spring to itself because we know every
variant in that phone by that pipeline
is going to be a false positive and so I
was quite worried about how I was going
to use all this false positive data to
kind of distinguish and it just turned
out when I looked at the quality scores
for the variations like output by the
software that I've been using and the
only false positive variants a very low
quality of the vast majority of them
whereas most of the variants that are
potentially genuine are very high policy
so we have a few kind of high quality
false positives but because we're in the
process of developing new techniques
rather than trying to get a really kind
of polished pipeline at the moment not
too bothered about those so instead of
having to do anything clever or
difficult all I needed to do was just
take the ones that had quality greater
than 200 wit and I was quite pleased for
so um yeah um our general approach is
basically to throw everything we can
think of at this problem and see what
works and what doesn't work and so we
actually also have the cadenza reference
genome though and I think that was
supposed to be open sourced in April so
it's probably open source by now but
then we're doing everything finding
variation from itself to itself to get
an idea of what your false positives
look like
and then we're going both ways so I'm
aligning all the cadenza reads to the
tiny spring reference I'm learning all
the Chinese spring reads to the cadenza
reference and then running the entire
sort variant calling pipeline sanity
checking filtering etc on each and I
also haven't yet worked out how I'm
going to work out whether when a Chinese
spring to cadenza variant is the same
variant as a cadenza to tiny spring
variants so if anybody has any ideas
about then I'd really like to know and
we were also trying as well as the
alignment based approaches and sort of
comparing whole assembly as to each
other so this is instead of taking all
of your raw data and just taking the two
reference genomes and aligning those to
each other and seeing where they vary so
this is kind of what this bit on the
right and signifies and this is proved
we thought this would be much easier and
but actually it's much more difficult
and unfortunately basically because of
what's not on my next slide bar and wine
expert one slide so I don't know quite
how much time I've got left though
because i think i've got five minutes ok
all right so and the next bit is just
sort of like my excuse for why i don't
really have any scientific results to
present at the moment and say in this
work I'm we have some of the largest
super computing resources in Europe I
started out doing this work on the
standard HPC clusters so this is for
jobs where you use less than 250 8gig of
ram and I found that my jobs were
swapping and that I had killed everybody
else's jobs so people missed deadlines
because I was running it on the wrong
hardware that was a bad mistake and so
then we moved on to we have machines
that I think the smallest one has about
seven tera bytes of ram and the largest
one has about twenty one obviously I
don't get to use that entire entire
thing at once but at least now I don't
have to kill other people's jobs when I
get things wrong which is quite nice and
that's also still too slow essentially
and so all the alignments alone took two
months on the UVs and that's partly
because I'm on there the scheduler kills
your job if you're going over your
memory allocation which is much nicer
for other people and like also if you
running things that take weeks and weeks
and weeks and your chance of having a
file system error or something going
wrong just like increases quite a lot so
I just had so many died but I'm so then
we move on to these and fpga so these
like field programmable gate arrays so
these are kind of you need a kind of
like hardware specification language I
don't know if that's the right word but
you need to it's it's more complicated
to use basically and I don't need to
bother about any of that because our
nice scientific competing guys have sort
that out for us and these take a hundred
and ten minutes for jobs that previously
took three to four days and however they
don't have a huge amount of storage on
there and transferring data than to them
is quite slow so I got what took two
months done in a week but I spent
literally most of my time just copying
things between locations and the other
disadvantage of that is that it needs
specifically modified software so might
like I have to do things on their run
them move the one to the other cluster
run a new thing and body body boss so
it's a lot of back and forth and in
terms of software so in
keynote earlier like the guy said quite
honestly like at the start he didn't
really know much about engineering and
it probably did a lot of bad practice
and unfortunately that's the same issue
in sort bio-informatics software so i
think the biologists like and they are
able to kind of produce things that work
in their use case but they're not aware
of the limitations of the software and
so just really stupid things happen and
like they've put a hard limit because
they imagine that you're always going to
use human data so they put a hard limit
as to the number of chromosomes you can
have and cuz usually for a lot of things
you can actually get your entire
chromosome whereas we don't have full
chromosomes we just have long like
scaffolds and they've just put what they
thought was probably a like a decent
limit a hundred thousand and actually no
we have seven hundred thousands and in
that one so I've ended up stepping
through a lot of software just to see
why it fails in your kind of see along
the way that is even if you fix the warm
way that it fails it's going to fail in
loads of other ways and so and yeah the
bits containing machine specific
instructions with quite quite painful so
and I yeah like finding software that is
actually capable of doing sort of work
and that I'm trying to do is again just
two months of getting pretty much know
where but I'm so this is a kind of plea
to people that can actually kind of
write software for big data applications
to come and write some bioinformatics
offer because we really really need you
so the final one is just if anybody has
any idea how to do this and then I'd
really like to know so a lot of my jobs
get killed because I read the
documentation and I trust the
documentation and I give it like a
hundred times more run
so that I need in a documentation and
and I check and as it's going along how
much it's using because i want to to get
things moving through the queues quickly
like you need to specify as little
memory as possible and but I've yeah so
I've had things where every time I've
tracked it is using about 200 gig and
then I get an email like a week later
saying it was going to like well over a
terabyte and so if anybody knows
genuinely like how to estimate the
memory requirements of sort of running
things like because I think a lot of two
tests are Donald tiny bit of a curve
that is a straight line and so if
anybody knows better ways of doing that
I'd really really appreciate it so thank
you and that's basically everything I've
got to say and so if you've got any
questions please let me know and I say
the research is funded by the BBSRC so
that's the biological sciences research
council and I this is a project that I'm
doing it the genome analysis centers so
thank you
yeah I think um so I think if you look
at the ensemble database and i'm sure
i've been told that the diploid one is
on that so is that the jaw room we okay
oh sorry which one's the like these
names ring a bell oh so i double-checked
the ensemble and sort of plants database
and and if not then I'm pretty sure that
they're on my way because i know some of
this stuff that we want to look at is
and sort of comparing these different
types so
aligning the chromosomes on at a time oh
so now we have we know which chromosomes
things are in so it's not just a massive
kind of dump though is so yeah it's a
bit difficult because the three graphs
genomes that it's formed from are all
very very similar so um and they're all
sort of like very homozygous as well and
they so it's very easy to put things in
the wrong chromosome and so we have our
guesses as to which chromosomes things
are in and through I think we have some
extra data that I've not looked at yeah
that kind of says which [ __ ] they are
more sure awful less sure of in terms of
which chromosome is in
yeah it's I mean I think fundamentally
we need to divide it into smaller chunks
occurs at the moment they kind of like
doing the whole genome things is just
not not working particularly well and so
but unfortunately like I don't have the
biology background to like know how you
divide it into smaller chunks so I do
everything that I kind in terms of
software to like paralyzed things and
break it down that way but in terms of
kind of getting the data set of small
manageable staff with and I don't know
um so yeah so i'm using the dragon
oh so we were able to build this
reference genome because the ring
because we got long enough reads to do
but I'm I so I think we need better sort
of repeat masking basically my so yeah I
said I think the algorithm needs
improving so actually like what what we
would like to do is there a sort of like
more kind of like to bruin graph based
algorithms rather than this sort of like
came a comparison algorithms and so the
way that we were able students of de
novo assembly was by using the sort disc
of our white debruyne graph approach and
so I well I think the reference is good
but I my i think that the alignment
techniques that were using on that
suited to the soul genome let me using
so yeah I'd I'd absolutely love to write
a so graph-based alignment tulus I just
say
yes so does I think we did is that the
my sig although it's so these all these
reeds are alumina reeds and I think we
um now I think we have used a long thing
and got but we've just got a small
subset of the really long ones because
yes they are expensive and then a lot of
kind of like backup ones or shorter
reads so that's one stunning in
so um Roslin is being recommended to me
I haven't used it I think they're mostly
interested like I got employed off the
back of light and having done like sort
of proper maths and so I've got a
master's in maths and saw a PhD in like
designing algorithms for quantum
computing so if you have a sort of like
math skills that you can sell as well as
some engineering skills then that will
but we can we can talk a bit later
though because they really like I think
they trying to get a big push because
these are like difficult technological
challenges and so they they're looking
for good people who can solve these
sorts of problems